This is our sun.
holy crap.
NASA just released AMAZING 4K footage of the
sun.
I'm gonna get off screen so we can just drool
at how beautiful it is.
This ball of incandescent nuclear fusion holds
our solar system together, and it's beautiful.
Every 10 seconds, NASA's Solar Dynamics Observatory
takes pictures of 10 different wavelengths,
temperatures, and layers of our sun.
In a star elements like helium, hydrogen and
iron are found in the sun’s atmosphere (the
corona), and each emits light at different
wavelengths.
Each color filter is a different heat level,
and wavelength so scientists can look at the
sun's layers.
NASA chose Gold for plasma here, and Bright
Green or Aqua for the flares
Purple and Blue are active regions in between
at 2 to 2-and-a-half million Kelvin
For example, this purple flash shows a flare
ripping through TWO layers, yellow and pink.
This is the first time we’ve seen our sun
in such high definition.
Now we can study the interaction.
For example, we’ve never seen coronal loops
this small.
These tiny eruptions are hot magnetized plasma.
(yellow)
Flare plasma is about 1 million kelvin, but
the flare itself can be 6 to 10 million Kelvin
-- by using and layering the colors, they
can show off how plasma moves through the
star.
Nothing on the sun is cold.
The "dark spots" are just cooler relative
to the bright spots.
Dr. Ian O'Neill Space Producer for DNews told
me HE looks at the small sparkles rippling
across the sun.
These are microflares -- basically small scale
flares that are sparked when magnetic field
lines interact with and accelerate the plasma
in the star.
Fibrils -- tiny plasma structures in the lower
corona that oscillate, like a shimmering pond.
Large flares like these are unimaginably gigantic.
Several tens of EARTH WIDTHS across.
But instead of rock and gas and you and me,
they're superheated plasma at millions of
degrees kelvin.
This is a magnetic eruption called a prominence.
The goopy stuff it threw off is called a coronal
mass ejection.
It's a stunning example of how magnetic structures
filled with cool plasma can be so powerful
they're hurled into space.
Solar storms can mess with satellites, affect
air travel, and knockout communications on
Earth.
Taking pictures of our star isn't easy.
If you point your camera at a light bulb it
washes out all the detail.
The sun is even harder to capture.
By capturing these, the SDO scientists are
learning loads about how the sun works, because
honestly, we don't know that much about it.
And it sure is beautiful.
For the full explainer including what THESE
are, check out our DNews' video on YouTube.
If you want to watch a 30 minute unedited
version of this video, there's a link in the
description!